Yeah.
As someone who was born two years after
the official collapse of the Soviet
Union,
it is hard to imagine the constant
possibility of global nuclear war and
the which the world lift for so long.
Do I have to know what happens when an
atomic bomb explode?
You all know when it come,
we hope it never comes,
but they to get ready.
There seems to be a substantial mount
off existential worry right now in 2017
births.
I wonder if it can compare to the way in
which the world must have been honing in
spreads in 90 62 when doing the Cuba
crisis.
Nuclear War seems births a moments away.
It arrogantly recommend that the United
States and the Soviet Union pump,
we'll remove the existing threat to the
security of the western hemisphere and
the peace of the world.
Isn't it therefore strange that when
Stanley Kubrick's 90 64 movie doctor
strange love opens with a nuclear bomb
of being refused,
it is this romantic song we are hearing.
It becomes clear that Kubrick has chosen
to turn the biggest threat to the world
into satire.
Existential dread is a great source for
satirical comedy and doing the 60s to
nuclear tensions were also satirized but
others,
Tom Lehrer,
both Harvard educated mathematician and
satirical songwriter roads.
This,
for example,
more of the bomb that drops on.
You get your friends and neighbor,
they'll be nobody left behind to debris
and we all go together when we
come back to that is to know you never
sold bereavement and inspiring
achievement.
Yes,
we all will go together when we go.
However,
I think no one's satirize the cult word
better than Stelly Kubrick with doctor
strange love.
It sends audiences books into laughter
and also serious worry about why anyone
could even love about worlds possibly
ending in a nuclear holocaust.
In this video,
I want to explore both the symbolism and
set of the film birth connected also to
the politics of den and the politics of
today by choosing this romantic song,
Kubrick tunes refueling the bombers in a
sexual act.
Dr Strange Laugh is a movie dead
ridicules the Cold War and nuclear arms
race by turning it into an allegory for
sex.
Johnathan swift describes one of Kuric
central teams in multiple of his movies
instead of the damned animal man.
Kubrick's characters are inherently
sexual and aggressive,
is weapons extensions of a sexual
organs.
He escapable off creating sophisticated
and complicated systems,
birth incapable of using them
responsibly and Morley.
Yeah.
Dr. Strange Loft presents in the film,
two kinds of men,
first of which is the military type.
These men cannot wait to drop a nuclear
bomb or Russia,
the main characters that embody this.
Our Channel Jack the ripper who sets the
whole plan to bomb Russia into motion
and general buck to Richardson,
Two d military men.
The Cold War is incredibly frustrating.
The movie ella crisis,
this frustration from a lack of military
action into sexual frustration.
Jack the ripper refuels the reason for
ordering the nuclear bomb,
I can no longer sit back and allow
communist infiltration.
Communist indoctrination.
Yeah.
Communist subversion.
Yeah,
and the international communist
conspiracy.
Okay.
The sapien and purify all of our
impressionists bodily fluids.
Okay.
And then later refuels he discovered
this infiltration when trying to have
sex.
Well.
I first became aware of it and then
drink during the physical act of love
as a,
yeah,
a profound sense of
feeling of emptiness motto.
The Cold War has taken away a sexual
virility and the only solution he sees
is dropping a load into modern Russia as
it were.
The same goes for general bucks.
30 Hudson.
He leaves his rather bimbo which
girlfriend right before having sex with
her to go through the ballroom.
He even says that his girl can already
start the countdown,
clear referral to the countdown off
launching nuclear strikes.
You just start your comp down and old
bucky,
we'll be back here,
but boy you can say stop.
You stand.
Of course sexually frustrated and can't
wait to bomb Russia
indicate that we would strive 90% of
their nuclear capabilities.
We went there for prevail and suffer
only modest and acceptable civilian
casualties from the remaining forest,
which would be badly damaged and I'm
uncoordinated
when the precedent for futures to do
this.
He starts chewing gum like a smoker,
chewing gum to not smoke.
He is chewing gum to distract him from
his sexual frustration.
Now movie is filled with Phallic symbols
such as the aforementioned refueling of
the bombers,
the Cigar General Jack The ripper smokes
the lung machine on the uses.
And at the end of the movie aircrewman
the Kong who symbolizes the biggest
direction note to men when he quote
unquote writes the bomb.
As Joan says,
swift said these are extensions of the
mill sexual organs.
The other kind of men in the film is the
one that doesn't want to drop the bomb.
He is a fiscally week sexually impotent
men plays by the same Ectera Dsr English
captain Lionel Mandrake,
the precedent Merkin muffly and doctor
strange love himself.
The English Captain Mandrake who tries
to stop General Jack The ripper is
fiscally impaired and enabled to use the
rather phallic machinegun referring to a
sexual impotence.
Yeah,
I uh,
I haven't had any much experience,
you know,
with those machines.
Yeah.
Got It.
Any of a professed a bathroom in my
sales pitch.
Heinrich in the name of the magazine in
the continental congress come in and
treatment.
That's a boy.
Yeah.
I'd love to come back time.
What's happened.
You'll see the string and my legs gone.
One,
Craig,
I've never told you what you see.
Gammy leg.
Yeah.
The precedent who dismisses all of the
military passion is rather wimpy and
weak looking when he calls the Russian
precedent.
It sounds like an all sexist marriage
where the emasculated precedent tries,
but Phil's to control his annoying
complaining wife.
Well,
listen.
How do you think I feel about it?
Can you imagine how I feel about it?
Dimitri,
why do you think I'm calling you just to
say hello?
Of course I like to speak to you.
Of course.
I like to say hello.
Not now,
but anytime.
Dimitri,
I'm just calling up to tell you
something terrible has happened.
It's a friendly call.
Of course,
it's a friendly call.
The last of the sexually impotent men is
doctor strange love,
also weak and physically impaired.
He is a scientist who used to work for
the Nazis.
He represents the Nazi scientist that
started working in the u s after World
War Two searches when from Brown,
who was also satirized by Tom Lehrer
gather round while I sing you a banner.
Fun Brown.
A man who's that lead jams Isru the by
expedia bought him a Nazi.
He won't even fry Nazi schmaltzy.
Sas Van are fine.
Doctor Strange love symbolizes
paralyzed.
It's not destroyed Nazi ideology.
When it becomes clear that the bomb will
be dropped.
He suggests a Bronco with many women
chosen for their sexual attributes to
repopulate the earth.
A suggestion that the Mescaleros
precedent likes,
you mentioned the ratio of 10 women to
each man.
Wouldn't that necessitate the
abandonment of the so called a
monogamous sexual relationship?
I mean,
as far as men were concerned,
yes,
it is.
You know,
a sacrifice is required for the future
of the human race.
I hasten to add that since each man the
it will be required to do,
but to just
service along these lines there women
will have to be selected for this sexual
characteristics,
which you have to be of a highly
stimulating nature.
Well,
book is showing about preventing a
nuclear missile gap after they leave the
bunkers.
After the nuclear Holocaust,
Dr. Strange loss,
paralyzed body is healed by this idea of
pure breeding inside the bunker while he
shouts out,
right.
Ending the movie with the nuclear
Holocaust.
While we hear a song about two lovers
death,
we will meet again.
No,
no,
no.
We need again,
sunny today.
When the film came out in 90 64 it's fit
in and satirize perfectly.
The political situation of it's time.
On the one hand,
it's ridicules Republicans search as
young Reagan and the presidential
candidates.
Very cool toddler who is aggressive
anticommunist pro nuclear expansion.
We're Toyak was criticized strongly by
Democrats who saw him this dangerous
warmongering.
See it sounds like it's a side job.
I'm big claim like a 52 jet exhaust,
fry them tickets to the bar.
He got a chance
in the week.
You miss escalators.
Characters in doctor strange love.
We see the so called wimpy EC has
Democrats search as Adelaide Stevenson.
He was called [inaudible] Bay.
Richard Nixon in 1952 the term refers to
intellectuals that are too out of touch
with reality,
the common people,
sexual interests,
et cetera.
In today's politics.
I think it's no surprise why so many.
We're worried about trump having access
to the nuclear codes with his sexual
remarks and x from the guts,
aggressive,
reactionary.
We're toric.
We seen him clearly,
Kubrick stamps,
animal men,
the passionate,
sexually aggressive military characters
in doctor strange love.
That is why many solid him,
a serious threat to nuclear stability.
Even though trump supporters pointed out
that when looking at actual policy,
Clinton Syrian policy would be much
worse for us relations and nuclear
stability or so people thought.
It's very clear that Dr strange loves
still holds up today in the movie,
the sexual tension was released sending
the world into nuclear holocaust.
Luckily in reality,
this never happens,
but the cold war and doesn't seem to
have ended after the fall of the Soviet
Union.
He bird has been simmering on below the
surface.
We hope it's willing to come to an
eruption birth.
It's still good time to rewatch Dr.
Strange laugh to become aware again and
also have a good laugh about the
possibility of nuclear annihilation.
I wish we had one of them.
Don't stay machine
because s Tom Lehrer sings,
at least we will all go together when we
go
and we were all go together when we go
boarding.
Back to that is to know you never sold
bereavement and inspiring achievement.
Yes.
We all will go together when we go all
go together.
When we go all suffused with an
incandescent glow,
no one will have the endurance to
collect on his insurance.
Lloyd's of London will be loaded when
they go
all fried together.
When we Friday,
we'll be French fried potatoes by and
there will be no more misery when the
world is.
I wrote disagree.
Yes.
We all will fry together when we fry.